من عمان ينضم الى منسق الامم المتحده
الاقليمي للشؤون الانسانيه للازمه السوريه
مهند هادي استاذ مهند اهلا بك معنا اذا
اردنا ان نلخص هذه الايام الثلاثه عشر
الماضيه كيف يمكن ان تقيم المساعدات والتي
قدمت الى شمال غرب سوريا شكرا لك ميسون
على استضافتي على شاشه العربيه مره اخرى
بالحقيقه
الازمه صعبه جدا والناس بمروا في ظروف
يعني غير غير لا تطاق الامم المتحده منذ
بدايه الازمه بدات في مساعده الناس بما هو
كان متوفر لدينا المواد الانسانيه التي
وفرناها بدايه هي كانت اصلا المواد التي
تقدم للشعب السوري نتيجه الحرب ونتيجه
العشر سنوات ومن ضمن مشروع الانساني ما له
علاقه في الزلازل ولكن استطعنا ان نضع
طبعا الزلزال في اولويات
الاستغاثه وفي اولويات برامجنا الاحتياجات
اكبر بكثير من من القدره الموجوده لدينا
حاليا لحد الان الامم المتحده ادخلت لحد
امس ما يقارب ال180 شاحنه هاي الشاحنات
يوجد عليها طبعا مواد غذائيه بطانيه خيم
لايواء مؤقت
ادوات صحيه وما يلزم وما يلزم المتضررين
التي تواجهكم استاذ مهند ما هي المعوقات
يعني بالنسبه لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه قل
بان هناك معوقات السلطات المحليه لا تسهل
الامور للدخول الى هذه المناطق ماذا يمكن
ان تفيدنا بهذا الشكل
طبعا بدايه كانت في بعض المعوقات
اللوجستيه لكن هاي حليناها في خلال 48
ساعه بدايه ودخلنا من باب معبر الهواء ومن
ثم كان في بعض المعوقات الاداريه
والسياسيه الحكومه السوريه فتحت لنا اتاحه
لنا بفتح معبرين اخرين وهذا اللي احنا كنا
نطالب فيه ولا نزال انه طالب بالوصول الى
شمال غرب سوريا من كافه من كافه المعابر
بالنسبه
لعبر الحدود من تركيا هذا الان جائز من
ثلاث معابر بالنسبه لخطوط التماس من مناطق
الحكومه لحد الان لم نستطيع ان نحلها هاي
المشكله الموضوع معقد واحنا عم نطلب من
جميع الدول التي لها تاثير ان يساعدونا في
هذا الحل لا بد من الوصول الى السوريين
اينما كانوا ولا بد من ولابد من عدم تسييس
العمل الانساني الناس بحاجه الى مساعده
فوريه
وطلبنا الجميع منذ اليوم الاول ان يضعوا
الناس النساء والاطفال هم الاهم في هذا
الوقت الحالي ليس السياسه المهمه الحالي
بالنسبه ايضا لهذه المساعدات المطلوبه
يعني كان هناك وقت عمليات الانقاذ كان
هناك حاجه كبيره بالنسبه
للرافعات للمكنات المتطوره التي تساعد في
عمليه الانقاذ الان خفت الامال كثيرا
وببعض المناطق توقفت عمليات الانقاذ ولكن
هل من الممكن ان يتم تامين هذه المطالب
وهذه الاليات لازاله الردم مثلا ويمكن
ادخالها الى داخل السوري ام من الصعب ذلك
نحن نعمل مع مع الجهات المانحه ومع جميع
الدول عملنا نداء استفاده
نداء استغاثه ب 400 مليون دولار لخلال 3
اشهر القادمه نامل انه يوصل الدعم المادي
حتى نتمكن من تامين كل هذه الاحتياجات
طبعا احنا يعني في هاي المناسبه نشكر
الدول التي تساعدتنا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه طبعا ما قصروا بعتوا كل ما بعتوا
الط لمساعده السوريين ولمساعده ولمساعده
الاتراك في هذا في هاي المحنه اللي بيمروا
فيها دول الجوار الاردن والعراق والدول
الاخرى لكن في الحقيقه احنا نطلب من جميع
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ومن خلال شاشتكم
الكريمه ان يحذوا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات بتامين المساعدات
العاجله لا سيدتي نحن بحاجه الى 400 مليون
دولار هذا مبلغ هذا مبلغ كبير لكن هذا
مبلغ نحن بحاجه
اولوياتكم الان هل تامين المواد الغذائيه
ام تامين الخيم ام تامين مباني مثلا
لهؤلاء المنكوبين
فتره ما بعد البحث والانقاذ اولا نحن
بحاجه الى تقديم الرعايه الصحيه هذا اول
هذا اول شيء بعدين بحاجه الى تامين مياه
مياه نظيفه سيدتي لحد الان احنا وصلنا
معلومات انه في حدود 47 حاله يشتبه بانهم
حالات كوليرا ونعتقد انه في عشرين طفل
ماتوا ممكن يكونوا بسبب الكوليرا لا
نستطيع تاكيد ذلك لكن الاعراض التي توجد
على الناس تبدو انها اعراض كوليرا هذا سبب
سببه اختلاط مياه الشرب باختيار اختلاطه
مياه الصرف الصحي ولهذا السبب نحن بحاجه
الى الى رعايه الى الناس بحاجه الى رعايه
الصحيه امنا امنا مياه مياه صالحه للشرب
امنا في حدود مياه صالحه ل60 الف من الناس
اللي موجودين هناك لكن بحاجه الى التاكد
نحن لتامين مياه شرب نظيفه لكافه الناس
اللي موجودين في هديك المناطق يوجد عائلات
يوجد عائلات مشرده يوجد عائلات بما بدون
ما برنامج الاغذيه العالميه نعم طالب طالب
بمساعده عاجله وفوريه لتامين المواد
الغذائيه سيدتي ست ميسون الناس اللي هناك
بحاجه الى جميع المواد الانسانيه شكرا لك
منسق الامم المتحده الاقليميه للشؤون
الانسانيه في الازمه السوريه مهند هادي
على المشاركه معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه